I think you know when things aren't
working as well as you would like if
things aren't going that well and you
perhaps aren't billing as much as you
would like everyone starts to have a
solution for the problem and everyone's
solution is a little bit better than the
other persons and you've got a cherry
pick which one you really focus on and
when you walk out that management team
everyone's got to get behind the
decision if you've developed a team
which as soon as they walk out that room
they're kind of up for it and they're
going to be up for that challenge and
they're going to move forward
irrespective of whether or not they
necessarily believed in it I think
you've got a pretty good winning formula
if they walk out that room and people
are like that's not what I believed in
then you've got a formula that's
probably gonna not end very well for
anyone there's plenty of warning signs
but I think ultimately it comes down to
easier Workforce harmonious is it happy
is it improving do you have those
constant small steps forward it might
not be the perfect solution for everyone
but are you constantly moving forward